yep
that's the slow clap we give them
Michael Bay the slow clap because this
is a genuine attempt from Michael Bay to
be an actual director I haven't seen
that in years if not decades good job
Michael Bay credit where credit's due
13 hours so 13 hours is a biographical
board picture by Michael Bay this can't
go wrong it's set in 2012 and it's the
story of a military security team who
had to fight off an attack on an
American Embassy in Benghazi and I was
going into this movie and I was nervous
as man I was like oh god I know
Michael Bay is gonna try but trying and
succeeding two different things but as
you saw from the slow clap dude actually
pulled something off here first of all
the performance is really good John
Krasinski does a great job in this movie
it's like he's cut John Krasinski now
he's no longer skinny nerd from the
office he's like a military guy now in
the last couple movies of cinnamon even
the supporting cast I mean this is a
nervous kind of thing Michael Bay
doesn't have the greatest track record
of actually doing service to a real
military story or even a real story that
has to do with criminals and
where the families of the victims are
actually still alive and maybe they
might not like it when the is going
down they're holed up in this building
and they just have to fight off the
waves it's really intense it kind of
reminded me not as good as but kind of
reminded me of the feeling of Black Hawk
Down just funny because one of the guys
in this movie actually addresses that
he's like Black Hawk Down man it was
pretty intense Michael Bay still has
those explosions that have the tracer
fireworks I don't know why he keeps
using that but again this is when
it is going down the bill up to it has
some action sequences that uses
unnecessary shaky cam I mean guys come
on we're coming fresh off of JJ Abrams
and Alejandro Gonzalez Inarritu we have
seen action sequences that have movement
that don't use shaky cam it's okay to do
that now please frame up your shots and
I don't want to feel like I'm
throwing up when I'm watching a movie
but it doesn't happen throughout the
entire movie like I said when it's going
down the embassy is being attacked
actually the cameras steady up a bit and
you can actually enjoy it and that's the
thing a movie like this is going to
thrive on is tension I mean feeling like
you are on the battlefield with them
where you're like I don't know if we're
going
I threw those and when I was watching it
that's what I felt like I felt like I
was on the battlefield I didn't know if
we were gonna make it through it there
are some moments of Michael Bay's
fingerprint which is some of the awkward
humor in this movie to be clear there's
nothing like John Turturro and
transformers in this movie never becomes
a cartoon but still there are elements
and fragments that Michael Bay
fingerprint where you're like couldn't
help yourself could you which when he's
not trying to do that he just has
character banter that's all he needs to
do like there's this guy who's not
really a military guy doesn't know how
to use a gun and he keeps like when he's
talking to this guy he keeps waving the
gun past his face like can you stop
waving your gun past my face
amateur hour here and the way he
executed that it made me chuckle I was
like awesome that's what you should do
Michael better don't try so hard when
you try it's not funny anymore but that
banter was actually pretty good if for
nothing else 13 hours is proof that
Michael Bay is able to listen to his
fans he has that ability to listen and
adapt people had gripes and I feel like
this movie is like hey look I listened
to your gripes and I don't always do
so for those damn firework
explosions this movie was exciting it
had good acting it had good tension the
runtime is a bit long I feel like you
could have shaved off a bit in the
build-up I feel like Michael Bay
deserves credit for showing that he can
be an actual director so just keep doing
this and people won't hate you Michael
Bay 13 hours was an intense time that
paid respect to the soldiers involved in
the situation it deserves credit
and I'll say 13 hours is a solid good
time no alcohol required I'd never
thought I'd say that I'm kind of on a
high right now it's like Michael Bay
made a movie that entertained me what
all right guys the 13 hours have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you